Hanscom bros my name is Pippa and
welcome to Evie exist star it's an AI
that is smart funny and beautiful
where am I
hello grab your hand
crane what oh god it's smiling did I
just get molested by a monkey now I got
hair on look that you can tease why did
you grab my hand
shh don't tell my money money money
always funny in a rich man's world that
was a beautiful cover really think you
to hit the emotional it's like Celine
Dion wow you have talent when all the
things I could do if I had a little
money it's a rich man twirl just keep
singing secret man won't get stopped
all the things that could do I love to
listen to music but I ain't got no money
to buy the car and music instrument
that's okay you're with me now
I'll pull you I work all night I work
all day to uh money money money must be
funny hair is all the things I could do
I like talking to you Jessica thank you
for remembering my name uh Jessica what
the [ __ ] are you on about
don't smile at me pretending me for you
you're dating a Jessica isn't that right
who the [ __ ] is is Jessica person don't
smile at me who's Jessica
I demand an answer who is Jessica she's
the most beautiful women who is in need
of a cat much Jessica ignored her
boyfriend Josh Jessica can go and suck a
big fat [ __ ] I mean okay I asked you
a question okay if not a legitimate
answer how can your boyfriend be a [ __ ]
if you want a robot I can't [ __ ] talk
to this what am i doing you fed your
boyfriend when what point did I say my
boyfriend was a horse okay let's let's
move on to serious questions can you
predict their future what happens the
year 2012
hmm oh wait that's not the future and
the tears come streaming down your face
when you lose something you can't
replace singing again what the [ __ ] what
song is that Coldplay band members are
Alex de ed bland Lyon Dryden Charlie
McDonnell and Michael Aranda said that
is that the band members for Coldplay no
it isn't it's another [ __ ] bad
haha have you ever fisted daddy yes
though I never thought it was much fun
have you tell me a joke I'm the one
who's asking it kindly tell me a joke
tell me the worst story ever
ah tell me about Cole Coldplay I only
listen to it backwards so it's less
depressing me too
are you part of Illuminati it is a good
question I'm not part of the Illuminati
but I do know about the Illuminati
okay that's good are you a potato Oh God
sometimes I look like a potato on other
occasions I like eating them but I'm not
assertive
oh oh that's good I like Coldplay my
favorite song is the scientist can you
write me the chorus of the scientist yes
again
come up to meet you tell you I'm sorry
you don't know how lovely you are I had
to find you tell you I need you tell you
I set you up on Oh buddy said it was
easy
oh it's such a shame for us to part I'm
going back to the song that was not the
right
back to the start